hi guys its Johanna here and today's
workout is called a new beast workout
this workout is designed especially for
those of you who has never done any sort
of workout before and you really have no
idea where to start but this workout is
also good for those of you who might
have workout many years ago and would
like to start working out again we'll be
focusing on all of the major muscles in
our body and really to awaken all of
those muscles that have been sleeping
for many many many years I'll be showing
you a series of simple yet very
effective workout to burn the unwanted
fat and also to strengthen the muscle so
let's get started so with today's
workout we won't be using any equipments
I mean if you have a mat using that if
you don't have a mat don't worry about
it the first workout is called squad and
tricep push back
so extend house by the side when it's
squatting down bring us forward and push
it back really squeeze that tricep so
bring it forward bring a squat it down
and push it back that's it bring you
forward and push it back bring it
forward and push it back so really make
sure you're going really low when you're
squatting down and really squeeze and
feel your triceps when you're coming
back up and sit let's go and darling and
really push your bum out and squeeze
your tricep push your bum up and squeeze
your side let's go up down
down and push that out really through
your bum and your tire legs working
together and at the same time if you go
try to squeeze it up down and up keep
going down and up down extend your arm
push it back extend your arm forward
push it forward and back squat and can
you feel that like some girls working
does your arm feel tired really when you
forward and push it back forward and I
keep going let's go let's do ten more
one two three down all the way no
cheating fall all the way down five six
seven squat eight squad squeezer shots
at nice squat and ten day job so that
workout just now was to really with your
quads your hamstring your back as well
as your tricep so moving on we'll be
doing my favorite workout which is
push-ups yes sounds difficult but it's
not because I'll be showing you the
easier version of push-ups so let's go
down onto the mat when it comes to crew
sharp we would really want to be
targeting our upper body
and I'm : same time so remember keeping
this together go down to the mat arms
chest apart lift your toes on the floor
and ready let's go down as low as you
can and up down up down up make sure
you're not aware standing or is not too
far back by your chest really go down up
up that's it your arms should be 90
degrees when you're going down
remember your entire body should be
going down as one unit I want to see no
one's sticking up on the air that's it
you should be feeling your chest working
your shirts working as well as the
tricep that's it down up down up as you
get down up down up keep pushing down up
that's it can you feel your muscles can
you feel your upper body working good
tighten it ass do not drop your core
really tighten you have sustained
dumb and elastic tail one two three
keep going four five six seven plus
three eight last two nine ten good job
and if you're feeling tired get into a
toughest position to stretch the upper
body up so just stretch it up just relax
for one and just shake it off
so we've done another body we've done an
upper body and the next one will be
focusing back onto our lower body and
obliques muscle the side muscle and your
core at the same time so this is called
the lunge and twist all right it's
simple as that
so get into a lunge position let's start
with our right leg step forward one leg
back down and when you're down twist and
that's it down twist and make sure you a
low twist and that's it no cheating down
twist and up you should between your
legs working Anna and your obliques at
the same time and that's it down twist
and down twist and up down up good job
keep going
come on keep going a more twist twist
six-foot doing the job down last four up
really twist last two last one good jobs
lost my mother's back now let's change
okay same thing one foot forward one
foot back jump and twist to the other
side down twist and up down twist and up
make sure when you're lunging down your
knees should not be going over your toes
all right keep your hands by your waist
that's it that's it can you feel your
legs burning good job come on keep going
we should really be weakening all those
muscles that has been slipping for many
many years
let's go back down twist em up
let's go anymore
good job really feel that leg down twist
up groups let's give up I more down
twist up or more take the job I'm trying
to keep my balance get last two and last
one good job so it's a heartbreak going
on you should be so just shake it out
and then just job on the spot
great how are you feeling feeling good
one more workout and we're done for
today this worked out we will be
focusing on oak all muscle
it's called plank I know most of you
have heard about plank so let's do it
because plank is one of the best workout
to work on a core hit focuses on your
abs and your lower back at the same time
okay so ready
let's get it to a plank position
producer view has never done a tag
before this is simplified version stay
on your knees bring your elbows forward
as such keep them 90 degrees and just
drop a bomb perhaps and just hope
basically it's a push-up position
ex
pushing up and down you're just holding
it and we'll be holding this time for 30
seconds today all right if this is still
single for you because you're like I'm
not feeling anything
let's go on tantos ready let's do it for
30 seconds tomatoes just hold it
this is wrong because your pump is
coming to life and this is wrong because
you're arching at that so we should be
in a straight position your body should
be in a straight line you get really
tight in the laps this plan it's all
about concentration if you can
concentrate touching apps do you have
that working through you have smarts and
working you're on a winner
all right so bogus well halfway that
just keep holding make sure you're not
watching your guy or sticking your bum
ah just keep holding it ten seconds nine
eight seven six five four three two and
one
good job and that's it so I guess that's
why we're back for today I hope you've
enjoyed it sweat a little bit and stop
your heart pumping remember if you don't
know any of this move or if you're
unsure about you know the right way to
do a squat lunges anything like that
check my how-to videos where I'll be
showing you and explaining each workout
and each moves in details and don't
forget to subscribe to my youtube page
for new weekly videos and nutritional
tips bye